let's go next to our caller from the
nine-to-five
area code who is calling today from 9:00
to 5:00 hi David
this is Rama can you hear me okay yes I
can Rama go ahead right on he David I've
been listening to you for well just
before Trump got elected so in 2016 I
always really dig your takes and it took
me four years but I finally became a
member last week
thank you so there's there's that
appreciate and then the the youngster
that just called before before me yes 16
years old I believe yes so props to him
for being being active and involved so
David with all the the stress that's
going on and the things that the world
is in the way it is my question is would
you would you be okay if I told a sunny
story of me having the chickenpox in the
late 70s and Richard Pryor you know I
don't think that that's a story that is
a good one for this particular show and
we also only have about a minute left so
I think I would rather hear what are you
doing during the quarantine well so I've
been I've been cooped up now for about a
month because both my wife and I saw
this coming
yeah and so we started social distancing
before anyone even started talking about
it mm-hmm so we've we've managed to stay
inside and try and get household
deliveries as much as possible we've had
to go out a couple of times to the store
yeah but that's what we're doing
thankfully my wife is a schoolteacher
and they had her start working from home
about three weeks ago and you're not
stockpiling like a year's worth of
toilet paper or anything like that well
so I'm an earthquake country so you
should you should have about a month of
goods
anyway right you know and well my wife
uses toilet paper like it's going out of
style
I don't get it but you know
the way things are what can you do with
that yeah so yeah here you just know I
love her anyway
so of course but I think the reason why
I wanted to tell the story you know to
make to make a laugh is because there's
some of us that watch your show that
have seen you had a legitimate laugh
where it comes right from your belly
right and it makes and it's in fact it's
infectious David I'm just saying
so if well listen if you ever want if we
have more time we'll do the Richard
Pryor story and of course but nothing
better than a than a belly laugh Brahma
thank you so much for the call it's so
great to hear from you and I apologize I
don't have time for that or other
stories today quick break back after
this